gottes gepostet
lieber mit den jungs sehr gut es geht
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video in dem wir euch heute wieder
bestens unterhalten werden und zwar hab
ich mir gedacht es gibt viele peinliche
bilder von mir da draußen auf der welt
ich hab nämlich vor einigen tagen man
twitter ausgesendet indem ich gesagt
heute schickt mir doch bitte mal die
peinlichsten bilder die er überhaupt von
mir habt oder gibt es einige als antwort
auf diesen schritt
das wären wir heute durchgehend und ganz
ehrlich das jetzt im nachhinein mit im
schnitt ich werde so viel zensieren
müssen ja sebastian l dessen pass auf
[Musik]
dass du dich noch an dem tag wo das war
ja das ist meine art gepostet jana dem
ok kurzer kontext dazu was für
gesichtsausdruck ist dass ich glaube ich
wollte irgendwie ich würde ihm so cool
sein es hat nicht funktioniert immer
wenn es ist einfach aus ist wenn ich
geistig gestört ist das bild ist
ungefähr 23 jahre eine älter ist das
glaube ich vier jahre wollte das war der
abend an dem wir in einem dorf
haftbefehl getroffen haben wer von euch
kein haftbefehl der von charles wissen
weder wo ist diese rapper und dieses
bild was ihr gerade seht ist ein
ausschnitt von dem bild mit haftbefehl
und jana hat den chemie gefunden doch
bester form habe ich immer geschickt
aber leute haben die kommentare bin ich
seitdem hässlicher als fetter geworden
mit schreiben vom 2
da ist ein klassiker ist ein klassik
leute dieses gesicht kenn ich so gut
stärke gewinnt das ist so üblich
sebastian hat er von unseren papa geerbt
der marke als auch damals noch das war
bei dunlop mehr ja alle leute schon die
kommentare geschrieben was macht er
skaten mit seiner zunge franken classic
ist das video echt ist ja ich bin keine
freundin mehr vertieft
es war ein londoner kann das ist aber
dennoch eine maus steht im bild ist ich
muss jetzt stark sein
also wollen hier bist du mensch der welt
bei mobile.de brauchen dinge wiedergeben
heute wenn euch irgend etwas einfällt
was ich mir in diesem moment gedacht
haben könnte dass ich so ein gesicht
gemacht hat dann schreibt es auch gerne
mal die kommentare im starken gerät auch
so ein typisches phase von sebastian
einfach einfach momente wo er mit der
gesamtsituation komplett und zufriedener
machen
das ist leider wahr
nein ich glaube nicht dass ihr diese
videos oder wenn ich es könnte auch
alles will ich glaube dass aus so einem
moment dieses ding in stunden oder so
locker sein
das macht ihr nicht so recht läuft bist
du weißt du was die story denn der ist
wenn euch irgendwas richtig abfahrt ja
dann müsste es einfach rauslassen
es könnte alles drin behalten die können
nicht den ganzen frust in rain saugen
deswegen muss man startup rauslassen an
box von alb eine wand oder man schreibt
mir einfach mal aber das war dem moment
wo ich am bodensee saß und bei minus 300
grad aufgenommen kontakt prof
wetterberichten da versucht mit den
fingern so zocken du siehst wie roth die
finger sehen
phoenix gesichtet das war das war so
also ließ was sagst du zu sehr sehr
modern sehr neu
düsseldorf das sind einfach alles bilder
die im internet frei verfügbar sind
ich finde ich nur keine freunde ich bin
doch kein job dicker fest was soll's wir
werden hier von mir aber auch sodinger
wo ich einen rosa kleine mädchen top
stehe im budget bei der abwahl geblendet
und wenn nichts gefunden haben heute das
war der moment in dem ich mich einfach
sofort ab ich habe nicht gehört dass
meine leute wie ekelhaft wir haben
dieses spiel gespielt max mit dieser
klappe daran wie du darauf gesprüht hat
wollen die haben also ins gesicht
geschossen ist ich fand das so eklig es
war nicht gespielt ich fand es im moment
eher weg dann ist er enorm
ich weiß ich weiß nicht ob es gemerkt
hat aber ich fand's ekelig würde sagen
es seinen klassiker dass bücher aber es
auch schon ab den wir denn ich einmal
erstellt habe ich mir noch mal diese
ananas frisur gemacht haben ich hatte
die geniale die analysen für bin ich
schön
wieso erst mal nach dem richtigen power
ding raus leute ich merke gerade einfach
dass meine existenz einfach vorbei ist
ich bin überrascht dass überhaupt noch
menschen soziale kontakt zu mir haben
wenn solche bilder und eure eltern euch
nicht auch gesagt dass sie immer genau
darauf achten sollte was ihr post im
internet habe ich gut gemacht hat
oh mein gott was gepostet motto mein
gott
leute wir haben es doch vor diesem video
darüber unterhalten dass wir hoffen dass
es dieses bild nicht ins video starb
dieses bild wahrscheinlich gerade
zensiert wenn ich nicht gerade richtig
dummen moment im schnitt hatte sich ihr
dieses krieg rezensiert weil das war
auch irgendeiner party und ich dachte
mir einfach ich habe mir diesen running
gag und ich dachte aber so jagen gehen
wir dem ein bisschen futter jetzt könnt
ihr euch vorstellen dass diese bild
drauf und damals haben nicht viele leute
mal sex oder contra volk aber natürlich
gab es ein paar herzensdame unter meinen
followern die das gespielt haben jetzt
posten
danke meinen augen verlören alle
ich glaub ich muss einen tweet löschen
sobald das video online ist muss ich den
tweet löschen auf den die antworten
kamen bei sonst keine jeder nachschauen
falls jetzt gerade gedacht habt ihr gab
es unterwegs sagt der in auf youtube
feiert ein bisschen ein problem seit
hoffe ich einfach dass ihr 18 seid und
niemand jährig ist es gerade im gesehen
dass ein bisschen geblieben seid
beschreibt auf jeden fall mal
heiligenbildern kommentare hier
wahrscheinlich würden die code erhält
ein lamborghini aventador aus in diesem
sinne bis zum nächsten mal drei macht's
gut